Speaker 1: All right. I said we were moving
on from the Hunter Biden cocaine story,
which has nothing to do with Hunter Biden like
they're calling it the Hunter Biden cocaine story,
even though there is no connection to Hunter
Biden. I told you earlier, cocaine found at
the White House in an area where public tours go
through and multiple Fox News hosts suggesting
it might have something to do with Hunter Biden,
despite the fact that there is no such evidence.
Here is another segment from this morning.
That's why I'm only getting to it now. Julie
Banderas interviewing former Congressman Jason
Chaffetz. And she does the listen. We're not
saying it was Hunter's cocaine, but we're asking
questions that nobody else is even willing to ask.
Speaker 2: I think they already know where it
is. I think they're trying to wait for the DNA
evidence. That doesn't happen in just a half a day
or a day. But the Secret Service, I do believe,
knows at this point who this person is.
Speaker 3: I mean, if you look at the way
that they're handling it right off the bat,
they're making it seem suspicious. We're not
I mean, we're just asking questions.
The reporters that are there in
the press pool. Right. But then if it's.
Speaker 1: Like when Tucker asks questions, do
brown people make the country dirtier and poorer?
Speaker 3: We're just asking the question. Look at
all the other networks. For example, all the major
broadcast networks last night, they all led with
the cocaine found at the White House. Not one one
broadcast mentioned the name Hunter Biden. Now,
we're not saying it's Hunter Biden. We're calling
it for what it is. The president's son is a former
crack cocaine addict and he's supposed to be
clean. He just was given a slap on the wrist for
charges that should have been felony charges. Why?
Because he's the president's son. So preferential
treatment obviously, is a very sensitive topic
when it comes to his son. And indeed, cocaine was
found in an area in the White House where Hunter
Biden has visited. So, of course, that's going
to be a question and there's no room for joking
about it. All the other networks making these
stupid jokes about there's no laughing matter.
Crack cocaine addiction is serious. And this is
a serious drug that was found in our White House.
Speaker 2: Yes, I heard one of those reporters
talking about, well, nobody got hurt. What
about the development, transport and all
of the other? I mean, that is just so ridiculous.
Speaker 1: He doesn't even know what he's talking
about. So, listen, I got an email from a lawyer
this morning who said, you know, David, it is not
yet at this point, but it is starting to border
on. It's not inconceivable that Hunter Biden may
be able to argue that some of these statements are
defamatory. Now, Julie Banderas is being sort of
careful in that. She's saying we're not saying
it's Hunter Biden's cocaine, which of course,
is code for. We sort of are saying it. We're
certainly implying it, if nothing else. But
putting that aside. A lawyer wrote to me and
said, if this went another step further, Hunter
Biden may be able to sue Fox News for defamation.
I don't expect it to happen, but it is compelling
stuff. The latest news, by the way, is that there
is going to be that apparently they have tapes,
there are cameras that are going to be able to
figure this out. And there's a report from Reuters
cameras, visitor logs searched after cocaine
found at White House and that now it may we may
know exactly who brought the cocaine. I am not a
betting man. You all know that. I really I really
just don't bet. I just save and invest my money.
I don't bet. But if I were a betting man. Okay,
My bet is that the cocaine is not Hunter
Biden's. If the cocaine is Hunter Biden's.
Write to me. Tell me what I should do. I'll do
something. If the cocaine is Hunter Biden's,
I'll buy, I don't know, donate to some drug thing
or I don't know. But if I were a betting man,
I would say this is not Hunter Biden's cocaine.